à 45 ans seulement durjamelouni étant
passe de marquer l'histoire de son pays
c'est trop mène dirigeante de fratellie
d'Italia défend une vision très
conservatrice elle a 15 ans lorsqu'elle
s'engage en politique et rejoint le
mouvement social italien une formation
fondée par des partisans de Benito
Mussolini c'est au sein de cette
organisation que Giorgia Meloni va
construire sa carrière en politique au
moment où toute l'Europe se réveille
après la Pologne la Hongrie la Suède et
l'Italie cette nuit et bien je vous
invite à devenir adhérent du
rassemblement national je suis très
heureuse de voir ce parti arriver aux
affaires car je crois que sa victoire va
contribuer à protéger les Français moi
je crois que qui Mussolini c'était un
bon pollution c'est-à-dire qui est tout
ce qu'il a fait il a fait pour l'Italie
malgré ses positions ultra
conservatrices et anti-avortement à 45
ans Georgia Meloni a su incarner la
nouveauté pour les Italiens ils se sont
tournés vers la seule candidate qui n'a
pas gouverné ces dernières années merci
de recevoir un ancien acteur il a une
plus belle cafphone carrière que la
mienne il est Président je suis rien du
tout
génial que vous
sur LCP ils avaient dépêché non pas un
mais deux journalistes à l'Assemblée
pour effectuer et c'est une première
dans l'histoire un duplex à très
exactement un mètre de distance dans la
même pièce l'arrière-plan le prouve
bonjour Stéphanie Despierre bonjour au
début janvier début février
alors l'audition ne devrait pas tarder
je vous le disais en quelques mots et
vous êtes à côté qu'elle est en tête
faire un duplex à deux enfin bon voilà
quand la technologie est au service de
rien c'était émouvant quand la réalité
dépasse la fiction la NASA va tenter
cette nuit de modifier la trajectoire de
l'astéroïde dimorphose un caillou de 160
mètres de diamètre ni écrasant sa sonde
d'art on voyait en novembre 2021
l'impact sera suivi depuis la Terre par
des dizaines de télescopes la déviation
le cratère les poussières éjectées
fourniront de précieuses données pour
développer les techniques qui
permettront à l'humanité de se protéger
contre un astéroïde menaçant le risque
de collision avec un météore de 150
mètres et d'un tous les 16000 ans mais
c'est seulement une statistique quels
sont les phobies de alors Grégory quelle
est ta grande phobie j'aime pas les
araignées quoi je suis pas très
classique mais j'aime pas ça quoi même
les toutes petites ou alors
pas de la phobie aucune jour le pas
comme ça mais je suis pas à l'aise
d'accord je fais chier allez viens
courageusement d'accord
Justine la grosse phobie
le télétravail peut devenir stressant
cette américain sans doute un peu les
nerf à vif a eu une visite surprise dans
son bureau un écureuil s'est introduit
par la cheminée puis à visiblement et
audiblement effrayer l'homme
heureusement aucun blessé n'est à
déploré une vidéo partagée des milliers
de fois par des internautes qui ont un
sens aiguë de l'humour
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai un truc mais je peux pas le dire à
l'antenne mais parce que
tout le monde
comme ça la Fashion Week de Paris qui a
débuté aujourd'hui pendant une semaine
les plus grandes marques vous propose
donc de découvrir les futurs petites
amies de Leonardo DiCaprio
[Rires]
voilà donc ce sera un peu sucré salé
quoi
tout à fait un peu plus sur l'acide
mais si c'était le contraire
au delà de ça c'est une affaire assez
trouble c'est sûr
faut pas nous mettre
ensemble saviez pas qu'il fallait pas
nous mettre ensemble
j'étais sûr que vous allez être une cape
c'est du pourri Dupont
bon je suis désolé
elle est encore en instruction la pauvre
elle est surchargée effectivement elle a
l'air quand même de la coupable bon bah
les femmes
attention première insulte dont vous
avez été victime
s'il vous plaît je suis un guignol mais
ça c'est pas une insulte c'est une
constatation
donc ça c'est un avis
je pensais qu'elle vous avait insulté
les Maliennes ce matin qui se battent
entre elles après une défaite face à la
Serbie
[Musique]